dota 2 has seen some changes over the
years and the latest patch is the
biggest update yet I'm Tony and this
game spot news update comes straight
from valve first things first we're
getting a new character The Monkey King
can attack with his staff leap from tree
to tree and even disguise himself patch
7.00 also makes some big changes to the
game overall the HUD has been totally
redesigned and you now have choices for
each character's perks as you level up
everyone also goes into battle with a
backpack these carry three inaccessible
items that you can swap into your active
inventory both the map and the character
select screen have been redesigned as
well and of course there are a ton of
balance changes you can view the full
patch notes on the dota 2 website patch
7.00 is live now on the test servers
with a full launch coming imminently so
what do you think of the changes will
you try out the new character let me
know in the comments or on twitter at
chain-gun hope and for all the latest on
dota 2 you're already in the right place
you